im nordrhein-westfälischen Mechernich im
Stadtteil Kommern baut das Land die
Bundesstraße 266 vierspurig aus dazu
kommt eine Lärmschutzwand für 900.000
Euro doch die Wand endet mitten im Ort
und nicht nur das neben ein paar
Wohnhäusern schützt Sie vor allem den
Friedhof die andere Hälfte des Ortes
geht weiter leer aus die Menschen werden
seit Jahrzehnten vertröstet wir bekommen
immer noch keinen Schallschutz ich
verstehe das einfach nicht der Friedhof
hat einen
wie gesagt die Toten werden geschützt
aber die lebende nicht das ist ein
Skandal und ich fühle mich total
verarscht das ist wirklich wahr ich
finde wir haben jetzt so viele Jahre da
abgewacht und immer wurde es verschoben
verschoben verschoben vor 36 Jahren
wurde schon beschlossen eine lärmutter
wurde schon verkündet also kommt der
Lärmschutzwand hin vor 36 Jahren seit
2013 plant der Landesbetrieb Straßen NRW
die B266 auszubauen sich seine wichtige
Verbindung vom Raum Köln-Bonn in die
Eifel Tag für Tag sind hier rund 17.000
Fahrzeug unterwegs im Mai 2021 gehen die
Bauarbeiten endlich los die Menschen die
direkt an der Bundesstraße Leben sind
sich sicher jetzt wird alles gut und
ruhig dank eines Super Schallschutzes
doch Pech gehabt weil der Ausbau kurz
vor ihren Häusern endet gehen sie leer
aus dafür herrscht jetzt auf dem
Friedhof himmlische Ruhe jetzt die
letzten Monate kriege ich mit dass das
wirklich
vor dieser Wohnsiedlung aufhört diese
Lärmschutzwand und das leuchtet mir
wirklich nicht ein ja also ich will
ehrlich gesagt nicht ernst genommen man
muss das wirklich sagen beim
Landesbetrieb Straßen NRW verweist man
darauf dass verwaltungsrechtlich alles
seine Ordnung habe die Betroffenen
hätten kein Anspruch auf eine
Lärmschutzwand die leben zwar an der
Bundesstraße befinden sie aber nicht
mehr innerhalb unseres Baufeldes für den
Umbau der Kreuzung das bedeutet der Bau
einer Lärmschutzwand oder lärmsanierende
Maßnahmen sind generell damit in
Verbindung zu setzen dass dort eine
Baumaßnahme von uns stattfindet weil
also der vierspurige Ausbau kurz vor dem
Wohngebiet endet schauen die
lärmgeplanten Anwohner in die Röhre irre
auf gut deutsch fühlen wir uns auf den
Arm genommen möchte ich sagen weil uns
seit so vielen Jahren eigentlich immer
wieder ein Lärmschutz versprochen wird
und jetzt doch keiner kommt wenn die
Feierabend machen gehen die Feier machen
die Feierabend und dann denken die
darüber glaube ich gar nicht mal nach
wie es den Menschen geht dies betrifft
in drei Wochen sollen die Bauarbeiten
fertig sein die Menschen aber müssen
sich weiter mit dem ungelösten
Lernproblem herumschlagen der Verkehr
wird sicher nicht weniger werden